ma sei ancora letto alzati su che é tardi devi andare a scuola non ci voglio
andare a scuola ho troppo sonno non
iniziare marina eh non iniziare ho la febbre
sempre la febbre hai tu eh sì sì certo si
vieni a sentire scotto
mamma queste vita mi stressa ho un crollo psicologico devo riposare mamma ma oggi
c'è sciopero me lo sono ricordato adesso
sciopero di che sciopero sciopero
di come tipo solidarietà per i bisognosi
é un nuovo tipo di sciopero mi sto vestendo
mamma ti giuro che questa volta c'è sciopero veramente ti dico anche di cosa allora
cisl cgl e ctl e cosa sarebbe questo ctl
un nuovo un nuovo sindacato si sono
sveglia mi sto solo preparando lentamente
ma oggi non posso andare a scuola e perché sentiamo perché ho scoperto questa nuova
youtuber che si chiama Maryna e mi
piacciono un sacco i suoi video però per
iscriversi al canale e cliccare sulla
campanella vicino al tasto d'iscrizione ci
vuole un pó di tempo quindi mi devi dare
un pó di tempo tipo tutta la mattinata
per farlo ah sì vediamo vediamo un pó se hai ragione
iscrivetevi subito al canale di Maryna e
cliccate la campanella
visto ci hanno messo un secondo ma
piantala va con ste scuse mamma é inutile
che vada a scuola perché alla prima ora
non c'e lezione la prof è malata
entra alla seconda così dormo ancora un pó dovresti saperlo quanto sono fragili i miei
bronchi se esco con questo freddo mi
prendo una broncopolmopeste
vuoi che mi succeda questo a tua figlia
mamma non posso andare a scuola perché
stavo sognando era un sogno bellissimo
parlava del bene che ti voglio mamma non
hai capitol'ho appena scoperto c'è stata una
perdita nei bagni della scuola e
l'edificio é inagibile
ah si e come fai a saperlo sentiamo chiamala intuizione mamma non posso andare a
scuola perché sto dormendo sono
sonnambula e non si possono svegliare i
sonnambuli sai
mamma non puoi capire ho fatto un incubo era temendo c'erano i mostri gli zombie dei dinosauri che mi
seguivano ti giuro sono spaventatissima
non ce la faccio ad affrontare la realtà ti
prego fammi dormire ancora un'oretta e
perché stavolta non puoi andare a scuola
mamma non puoi capire meteopazzerello.it che é un sito affidabilissimo ha
detto che c'é l'apocalisse non si puó uscire c'e' l'allerta meteo e le scuole sono chiuse
ma mollala saranno due gocce dai non
fare ogni volta la tragedia dai ma se ci
sono sacche d'acqua che crollano dal
cielo mamma mi é appena arrivata la
lettera da hogwarts mi hanno presa
domani parto
eccola dove era la mia bolletta del gas
brava expelliarmus hai finito stai
attenta eh che se no ti faccio
l'incantesimo io e faccio sparire tutta
la baracca qui va bene muoviti mamma mi sono arrivate sto troppo male un'altra
volta eh non le hai avute già scorsa settimana
hai ragione allora è grave é gravissimo
bisogna andare da ginecologo subito e no non
posso andare a scuola e sai perché
perché sto preparando un esame e se non
passo quell'esame mi bocciano e se mi
bocciano devo rifare l'anno
e se ripeto l'anno non mi prendono all'
università e se non mi prendono all'
università non mi laureo e se non mi laureo non trovo lavoro e se non trovo lavoro muoio
di fame vuoi questo per tua figlia eh
mamma sto studiando troppo ultimamente
ho una stanchezza accumulata che cioè proprio mentalmente non sono pronta a studiare
altro devo fare un pó di pausa perché
se no impazzisco cioè troppo studio troppa
cultura qui dentro
ma come non hai mai sentito parlare della
teoria che dice che le persone che
riposano di più hanno più successo nella
vita
assolutamente no che caldo cosa hai detto no nien
dico che che sono troppo calda mamma
guarda si è spento mamma ti giuro 54
gradi è gravissimo é grave
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine del
video spero tantissimo che vi sia
piaciuto mi raccomando fatemi sapere con un commento qui sotto se avete già
utilizzato una di queste scuse o se
avete trovato delle idee degli spunti
per le nuove scuse da utilizzare
ricordatevi inoltre di seguirmi su tutti
gli altri social facebook instagram e
tiktok io vi mando un bacione e me ne torno
a dormire yeaaaah adoro ciao